what kind of guys are usually successful
with modern women
[Music]
yeah yeah I just wrote that one fresh
fresh so what kind of guys are
successful with girls or women like you
look
oh like me you're no mother so I think
I'll I'll know her as well yeah
she said she's traditional I know
I know what she said I'm basic I'm
modern I know I'm
so so what kind of okay in your mind
what kind of guys are usually successful
with more than women
yeah both of you you know I believe like
I need to have a personality with most
of the people doesn't have the pretty
material things guy think like oh I have
a defense car
or like I don't sleep with the car I
sleep with the person so for me it's
much more important what they can bring
to the table in a conversation or how he
treats people is much more important so
for a mother woman it doesn't matter his
income it must count is the company
quality his car his income doesn't
matter no because the modern woman can
work and it can have their own money by
the things she wants okay is that
is that all yeah that's all that's all
personality and what personality if you
have a personality
okay that's uh that's that's interesting
uh what do you think
sorry repeat the question what kind of
guys are usually successful with modern
women
um
the ones that like keep girls on their
toes when I say that I mean
well me personally I like adventurous
like if someone just makes people alive
you've got my attention like how does a
guy make you feel alive how do you do
that for the guys that wanna for the any
other guys watching that wanna date
girls like you how does he make you feel
alive I want to know this thing
how does your mind work cheating no
um so
me [__] I'm I'm an adventurous person I
like
adventure and when I say Adventure I
don't mean that Indiana Jones I'm
telling you all of that I love it like I
swear tell me we're going to skydiving
next week I'm there black that's I like
that kind of stuff so the guys how many
times have you been skydiving I haven't
because the guys I don't the guys no no
wait let me explain let me explain let
me actually explain because this will
make sense this will make sense because
the guys they're good at manipulating
your brain never done it I don't say I
love it I said I would do it different
there's a there's a difference come on
all right so do we get a not doing it
yeah there's a difference I would do it
I would do it doesn't mean I've done it
I would do it and how does a guy make
you feel excited come on
so they will tell I think I me
personally I get excited by the idea
which is
a bit messed up but they will do like
this fantasy thing and it'll make me
think oh yeah this is gonna happen this
is gonna happen and it will go left
oh so basically what's that sign is when
a guy sells you a dream yeah yeah it was
at noon that's how it was in the case
yeah the dream is the dream that yeah
what kind of dreams do you usually get
sold
you're my girlfriend now look for kind
of dream no not that one I don't see
yourself
what makes you run I don't like that if
a guy feels odd like my real girlfriend
now not if I'm not ready no
that's me out still
so
so what are you looking for when you
when you I said advice just Adventure
let's say the first date if you say just
find me in Heathrow I tell you later
would you go would you feel exciting
like
I want to know what these Adventures are
because you're just saying anything
what Adventures have you ever personally
that made you like a guy
I don't want to talk about them but
there's no Adventures there ain't no
Adventure there is I just choose not to
say them right you went to you went to a
restaurant I don't do restaurants see
you've already gone wrong because I
don't do restaurants
like a sexual thing when you say I don't
want to talk about it yeah did you leave
the country
I have once no she's talking about with
the guy that's what I'm saying like was
one it was just a different like it's
just there is stuff there is stuff but
not sexual why won't you tell us then
was it is oh is he a criminal
what no because like obviously if you
don't want to talk about it it's either
gonna be sexual or it's not enough I
like I like things that make me feel
like excited like adrenaline junkie I
love it there's just different stuff
you're making it sound more and more
sexual to me that means you guys got
dirty minds because I'm not even
thinking about that
I mean what would you not want to say on
a pirates are either illegal or sexual
like why just you know like
how do I explain it it doesn't have to
be that deep like you guys are thinking
like flying out all that I just like
things are exciting if that makes sense
oh roller coaster yeah I just yeah I
just like those kind of things so you
take you on a rollercoaster guys all you
gotta do nope that's not modern women
yeah they want to be excited roller
coaster yeah but most girls most girls
you need that money
okay all right so okay cool like we've
been going around around in circles for
too long at the end of the day what
you're saying is that if I got to be
successful with a woman he has to be
exciting that's what you're saying yeah
okay and you're saying that yes I have a
good personality personality
don't forget that I'm older than her
yeah I know you're definitely gonna have
different like mindsets because of age
obviously all right
can I ask my mom a question can I ask my
mom mom what is that okay okay Mom what
do you think um women should look for in
a guy
assuming they want to get married yeah
yeah like if modern women are thinking I
need to be a wife tomorrow
they need to look at their
um
I mean work ethic for sure hands down
big big item
um and will they be good Fathers I mean
assuming you want to have kids I
couldn't even imagine a world without
kids so
um I would say those two things and then
you know I think that there's a lot of
commonalities you know we're always
looking for something new and exciting
and different but the truth is is that
we often marry our dads we marry our our
moms whatever it is and so you know do
they emulate where you came from because
usually that's where you end up
not definitely so what do you think what
type of guys are usually successful with
more than women with modern women in
general oh gosh well I would say
cheaters for one yeah because I have
done
since for sure women love the cheaters
and Destiny came on here yup talking
about you Destiny and was like oh Pearl
modern women don't like getting cheated
on but why is it when I do these Street
interviews oh have you ever been cheated
on yes so we're all picking cheaters
right and then I'm like okay did you
leave or did you stay and they all
stayed they didn't leave okay and then
I'll be like when did you leave did he
cheat again is that what made you leave
no so I'm thinking two plus two equals
four modern women love cheaters if you
want her to stay keep on cheating she'll
she'll stay with you for a lifetime she
will also cheats on him as well she's
modern she respect hers
I'm not saying she won't cheat back she
might but honestly I see I see the
opposite I see women cheat on Sims more
on the guys that just like take whatever
and like we'll do whatever for her I I
see them cheating on them more and being
more loyal to the cheaters I'm not
saying I'm happy about this I'm not
saying this is the right way to go I'm
just saying what I see and maybe who
knows maybe I'm blind
maybe they maybe they date cheaters
because then it gives them the license
to cheat if they want to you would you
would think so no no
I I think I think women I think women
cheat more on the nice guys you would
you'd be surprised Mom it's true I agree
with you more time
you agree with that yeah the nice guys
finish lost okay cool was he gonna say
um I feel like more time a lot of girls
feel like they can change them I'm that
girl that is not going to cheat on Black
even though you found out oh these
ghosts he's cheated on I'm gonna be that
one you know what yeah do you know what
yeah like I I think the cheating aspect
is a valid point but with that is not
really the answer to the question
because what is it about the Chia that
makes him attractive and what is it
about the cheetah makes the woman stay
that's what I'm really trying to get at
with the Christians he's the kind of
guys
are successful what kind what is the
traits what's the what is the makeup of
that guy I can tell you it's be
it's dictionary adaptation because all
right you know back in the olden days if
I was looking I was like who can I make
a child with and I see man a man a has a
harem of women I'm thinking all right
all those women picked him
so I should pick him too because they
picked him so he's got something worth
picking right on top of that it also
signals he can take care of the kids he
took care of all their kids so I mean he
could probably take care of all my kids
where guy a nobody's picking him why
isn't anyone picking him you know it's
like it's like what does nobody want him
can he not take care of the children
what's wrong so I'm not saying this is
great but it is an evolutionary
adaptation we can't even help that we
like cheaters goodbye
what does Pearl's mom think about it
what kind of guys do you think are
successful with modern women elusive
elusive
um
okay because they feel like they can go
get any guy so the one that they can't
get is the one they want who
in your mind what's the image
of that elusive black guy
tell dark and handsome hmm
and the uh first one this is the first
one bro and he's got a thick wallet
thick one or he's at least got the image
of a thick wallet
[Music]
anyway so what do you what do you think
about what does what does he look like
the successful guy with women what with
modern women what does he look like
do you agree tall dark and handsome yeah
yeah
nice car I think it's it's the guy's fun
he can be poor ugly fat whatever he
gonna get any girl he wants when he's
fun to make people last illusion brav
that's the illusion it's true
so basically you're saying any guy can
get any bro where you reject guys think
about it
has every guy got a chance with you but
of course not of course exactly yeah so
if you if of course not every guy has a
chance to read so why would you say that
any guy doesn't matter if it's tall
short fat well it doesn't matter
actually because it matters to you it's
about opportunity people just use data
for those days I rather meet people in
real life and then when you consider
personality let's say it doesn't matter
how the look the guy has but if you make
me laugh if it's a funny guy so have you
slept so every guy that has made you
laugh have you had an entanglement with
every guy that's approached you and made
you laugh have you had an entanglement
whether you slept with them or had the
relationship or uh hook up or anything
like that every single time
no no exactly because there's some guys
you're gonna reject it's not feasible
for you to give everyone a chance you're
gonna have to have some kind of
preferences there
I don't think
yes but I I don't think it is always a
Bop no there is a butt because I don't
think it's just physically you know I
think it's the package of the man what
he can offer how he treats people how he
treats his mother is really important
for me as a sample I always ask yeah but
you're not gonna know how he treats his
mom when you first meet him all that
you've got is that first impression
that's all you got in the first 10
seconds you got an impression is he tall
is he sure is he fat does he look
unhygienic because he got bad breath is
he got Gamers he whacks this is
important that's what I'm saying so when
you say personality and just be fun and
as long as he's nice to his mom I mean
bruh at the end of the day you rejected
guys that probably was nice to their mom
and funny and all of that stuff and you
rejected him because he's too short or
he's too fat or he wasn't you know he
wasn't the type of guy that you find
attractive and that's it as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible